BILL LUAN: It is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
I think--
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, welcome everybody.
This is the first of a series
of Chrome Apps Hangouts.
My name's Pete LePage.
I'm a developer advocate
on the Chrome team.
And I'd like to introduce you to
a couple of folks who we've
got with us today.
We'll start with Paul.
PAUL LEWIS: Hi, I'm Paul.
Paul Lewis.
There are a lot of Pauls on the
Developer Relations team.
So I'm Paul Lewis, I work on
essentially the Chrome team,
and I'm on the Chrome
Apps team as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
And Paul, you're in
London, right?
PAUL LEWIS: That is
correct, yeah.
London.
PETE LEPAGE: Awesome.
All right, and I'll pass
it over to Renato.
RENATO MANGINI: Hello, guys.
I'm Renato Mangini, and
I'm based in Brazil.
I am also a developer.
I am engineer for the
Chrome Apps team.
Yeah, that's it.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
And so you're in Brazil and--
RENATO MANGINI: Yes.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
And so I'm here in New York.
So we've got a pretty wide
range of folks from
all over the world.
And we've been working on Chrome
Apps now for the last
couple months.
We announced Chrome Apps back at
Google I/O, and there were
a couple of sessions that
we had at Google I/O.
If you haven't had a chance to
check those out, you should
check those out.
We'll put the links to the
videos in the comments after
the fact, but there were two
sessions that were presented
at Google I/O. The first
one was just a general
introduction to the
next generation of
Chrome packaged apps.
And then the other one was how
to convert or how to upgrade a
web app to a Chrome
packaged app.
As we started thinking about
building these Chrome packaged
apps and how they evolved, there
were a couple of things
that we thought about
and realized.
One is that the web ecosystem
is really thriving.
Chrome has more than
310 million active
users around the world.
We've seen many, many
applications downloaded from
the Chrome Web Store.
And users are just asking for
web apps all over the place.
And we wanted to take web
apps to the next step.
And so we tried to focus
on four key components.
The first is really about
breaking out of the browser so
that web apps feel like they're
installed, and they're
native on your computer.
They interact in the same way so
that when you click on your
doc or on the Start menu, the
applications are just there.
And they don't have
an address bar.
They don't have a Back
or Forward button, or
anything like that.
The second piece was around
enhancing the UI providing a
much better UI that is
completely configurable by
you, the web developer.
When we say we take away the
address bar, the Back and
Forwards button, that's great.
But the thing that it allows
you to really do is go and
specifically design how the bar
looks across the top so
that it looks how you
want it to look.
The third piece we focused on
was making these apps work
offline by default.
And offline by default is kind
of a loaded comment.
It's got a lot of different
meanings.
But there's a couple
of pieces that are
really important there.
These apps should work--
once they're installed,
you hit Run,
they should just work.
Whether you've got a fast
internet connection, whether
you've got a slow internet
connection, whether you've got
an intermittent internet
connection, these
apps should just work.
And the reason that they just
work is because we've taken
all of the resources, the HTML,
the JavaScript, the
images, all of the assets for
the application sit locally on
your computer.
And then any of the other
resources, the data that may
go back and forth, is the
only thing that's
transferred back and forth.
So everything in order for the
app to run sits locally, but
the data goes back and forth.
And then, finally, the last
piece is we wanted to give web
developers access to things that
they've never had before.
In general, we kind of split
them off into two different
categories--
system-level access and
service-level APIs.
With the system-level access
stuff, you have access to
things like the networking stack
so that you can actually
go and do raw TCP or UDP
requests, right?
You could never really do that
with a web app before.
If you wanted to do something
like that, the most you could
do is do an XML HTTP request.
Maybe you could do a web socket
or something like that,
but you couldn't actually
go and do a
raw TCP or UDP request.
We also wanted to give
developers access to the USB
in serial and Bluetooth so that
you can actually go and
write apps that are more
powerful than ever before.
You can plug an infrared
blaster in.
Or you can go plug-in, oh,
say, some LEGO Mindstorm.
We'll show that in
a little bit.
But really being able to plug
applications and make them
more powerful, let them
take advantage
of the entire system.
So by allowing developers to
really build these things, we
get a much bigger and more
powerful set of APIs, and we
allow developers to create much
more interesting and much
more exciting applications.
So with that, I'm going to put
a little video on, and we'll
have Paul talk about
that video.
So let me get this video
lined up here.
All right, so, Paul, I'll start
this video, and you can
talk about it.
PAUL LEWIS: All right, super.
PETE LEPAGE: So they can
see the video now.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, great.
So what you're seeing is a LEGO
Mindstorm's NXT, which is
just off the shelf.
We didn't make any firmware
changes or anything like that.
And what we did is
in two days--
so you can build these
apps pretty quickly.
We set up Serial over Bluetooth
to talk to the robot.
We're using, as you're probably
seeing in the video,
the Gamepad API with Renato, I
think, controlling the little
robot there with the Gamepad.
You can also see on the
left-hand side the
visualization of what
the robot's doing.
We used D3, which is a great
visualization engine, and a
bit of CSS 3D as well.
So you can build these apps with
all the technologies that
you're used to.
And you can see, as I say,
that we used Serial over
Bluetooth to actually talk
to a specific device, get
feedback from the device, or
using JavaScript, HTML, CSS,
all those technologies that we
use on a day-to-day basis.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, this was
something that you guys built
just over a couple of days, just
before I/O, as a proof of
concept, right?
RENATO MANGINI: Yes, exactly.
We built it like on Friday and a
Saturday the week before I/O
because we wanted to show--
to present cool stuff on our
Chrome Office Hours on the
Google I/O floor.
So yeah--
PETE LEPAGE: And it was
pretty popular.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, exactly.
Like some people say, if you
put some robots, you always
get a lot of views.
And if you join robots and
bacon, you explode.
I was trying to do some demo
with bacon included, but I
couldn't figure out--
I had not much time to
figure out that.
PETE LEPAGE: We could maybe get
a USB frying pan to cook
the bacon and then--
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, I thought
about that, but that
wouldn't be very safe to
present on Google I/O.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, it might--
RENATO MANGINI: There were
a bunch of people
trying to get the bacon.
PAUL LEWIS: Have the robot bring
you a bacon sandwich.
What I should say is that the
code for the robot is
available on GitHub.
We'll have the link up
afterwards, but it's
github.com/googlechrome.
And the repo is called
numberhtml5-app.
So we'll link to that
after this.
PETE LEPAGE: So we'll add the
link to that in the comments
as you watch the video
after the fact.
So cool.
PAUL LEWIS: All right.
Great.
PETE LEPAGE: Renato, do you want
to give us a bit of an
architectural overview of Chrome
packaged apps, how they
work, what's going
on with them?
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, sure.
As the audience probably knows,
this is the beginning
of a long series of Office Hours
about Chrome apps, and
we will be covering
several APIs.
You will talk about
that later.
So this is a very high-level
overview of
what is a Chrome app.
Let me screenshare
my screen here.
Can you see it?
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
All right, we've got that up.
RENATO MANGINI: OK.
So the idea of a Chrome app is
not to be a website, is not to
be a standard web app.
As Pete mentioned, the idea is
to be as powerful as native
but easier to maintain, easier
to code if you are a web
developer, and more secure than
native could ever be.
Well, the application
stays in the cloud.
The user always installed your
application from the cloud,
but after the user installed
your application locally, the
user can execute that
any time he wants.
So I think from the four points
that Pete mentioned on
his talk, the most important
from the developer point of
view, the most important thing
you have to have in your mind
[INAUDIBLE]
Chrome app is that
it's offline.
Because that changes
your mindset.
That must change your mindset
as the developer.
The programming model
of a Chrome app is--
the main point is the
background page.
The background page is, although
it's called page,
it's in fact a script
and it's invisible.
So there's--
PETE LEPAGE: Let's just stop
for a sec there because I
think that's a really
important point.
It's not quite a background page
as you think about it in
the traditional background page
for one of the legacy
Chrome packaged apps, but
it's actually just
a script that runs.
So you don't actually have
to write any HTML.
It's just some JavaScript,
right?
RENATO MANGINI: Yes, exactly.
Exactly.
The idea of this script
is to create and
control other windows.
It's like a central piece of
the whole application.
If your windows have to
communicate one to each other,
ideally they should use the
background page as the central
point of communication.
Also, to create other windows,
ideally you should use a
background page to create
those windows.
The background page
also listens to
user and system events.
Of course, any page can listen
to user events, but the
background page--
as the central piece, it can
also listen to other events
that a page cannot listen.
We will discuss these specific
events when we
talk about each API.
So this is just a high-level
overview.
And this is very important.
The background page, it
runs every time your
application is running.
And eventually the user can
quit your application.
But the system can also--
if there is no other windows
being shown, the system can
suspend your background page.
You can listen to this event.
I will talk about that step
now on the app lifecycle.
This is a very simple
lifecycle diagram.
You can see this on our
documentation pages.
And this is after the
application is installed.
So the user has the application
installed.
And it clicks on Run.
It clicks on the application,
and
event onLaunch is executed.
What is called event
page on this
diagram is actually called--
it's a background page I
mentioned before, OK?
So the event page can or
cannot open windows.
If it does, it goes through
the windows open state.
If it does not, of course, it
goes through no windows open.
But the most important thing
here is that onSuspend's only
called when there's no other
windows open or there's no
windows open.
Of course, you can get this both
onLaunch and onSuspend
events and do whatever
you want.
In the case of onSuspend, you
cannot do much things.
It must be fast.
You cannot do any asynchronous
call or anything
that takes too long.
It should be fast so you don't
impact on the user and on the
usability of your app.
OK, so this is the lifecycle
of an app.
But what is really an app,
the contents of an app?
Paul will show you a Hello,
World app right after.
But just to give you
a rough idea--
that is composed
by a manifest.
If you are an extension
developer or a Chrome app
developer, you know
what it is.
There are a few changes from
the event manifest.
But basically, if you are
not already an extension
developer, a manifest contains
meta information, permissions
that your app requests to run,
and the information on what is
the background script that
should be executed.
One relevant point here.
On a traditional web
application, not a Chrome app,
you ask permissions, and the
permission pops up on in front
of the user.
The idea of a Chrome app is that
most of the permissions
can be given to your app when
a user starts the app.
So the experience from
the user's point of
view is much better.
Because if you are using an
application that requires
access to your USB device,
probably if you install that
application, if you agree with
that permission, that's OK.
You don't want to get that
pop-up every time you run the
application because the
application hasn't changed
what it requires from you.
So all of that goes on
the manifest JSON.
The background script is the
script that you put on the
manifest and it's the script
that will listen to the
onLaunched event and do
whatever it has to do,
depending on your application.
Usually it will create
one or more windows,
but it can do anything.
And I think this is the most
important thing for a
traditional web developer.
As I said before, you have
to change our mindset.
You are running offline.
So you have to think about what
your application needs to
run, and you have to put
it all on your content.
You don't have to depend
to get this
information from the network.
OK, so yeah, that's a
high-level overview.
Do have anything to add?
PETE LEPAGE: All right, no,
I think that's good.
The cool thing is if you've
written a legacy Chrome
packaged app, you're already
well on your way.
And it's just a matter of making
a few changes and then
starting to dive into some
of the new APIs that are
available to you.
If you've written just a web
app that's hosted, you're
going to have a few things that
you're going to want to
play with and change
and learn as--
RENATO MANGINI: Like embedding
everything on the same package.
PETE LEPAGE: Exactly.
Exactly.
But really all you're doing is
taking all the files and
putting them into
the zip file.
Instead of having them sit on
the server side, they're
sitting on the local side.
Cool.
Well, Paul, do you want to tell
us about some of the new
APIs that are available?
PAUL LEWIS: Definitely.
OK, so we've heard a bit about
the overview and the
architecture and those
kind of things.
And so one of the things that--
as we mentioned at the
start, we've got these new APIs,
specifically some of
these system-level APIs, which
I think are really exciting.
What I want to do is
I just want to
highlight a few of those.
What I'll probably do is show
you my screen in a sec.
Let's do that now, actually.
So if you were to go to
developer.chrome.com/apps, and
on the left-hand side you've got
the menu, the interesting
one is the Chrome JavaScript
APIs, which gives you an
overview of all the APIs that
are available to you in your
Chrome packaged apps.
Now, I'm not going to go through
all of them because it
would take quite some time, and
you want to probably dive
into this and look at the things
that are of particular
interest to you.
But there are some new
ones, and you want to
probably look at those.
Context menus are quite
interesting because those are
things that you'd expect
to see in a native app.
So we wanted to give you those
as well for your--
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Those give you the right-click
on items or
on whatever, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
exactly right.
So these are things that almost
any user of your app
would expect.
If they're going to be launching
these apps outside
of the browser, they can
start right-clicking,
those kinds of things.
As I say, you can dive into
some of these more
specifically yourself.
The socket I found particularly
interesting
because now you can actually use
your app as a TCP or UDP
client, which is the first time
that you've been able to
do those kind of things
directly.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, what kind of
apps could you write with the
TCP and UDP APIs?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
so some people
have written IRC clients.
Renato, what else
have you seen?
RENATO MANGINI: Well, that's
a whole new apps--
I think this opens up for
a whole set of apps that
requires a network.
I cannot even imagine what
develops will come with--
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, that's kind
of the cool part, is we have
no idea what you guys are
going to do with this.
Cool, you want to keep
talking about--
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I mean, the
thing about sockets is
historically with web sockets,
you need to be able to control
both sides.
Now with the TCP socket stuff
particularly, you're in
control of the app side.
But the service you're talking
to may not support traditional
web sockets, but they may
support TCP connections.
So it just broadens
what you can do.
The thing that I've got on the
screen is this experimental
APIs, which contains some of
the really interesting ones
for me personally, but
particularly, the Bluetooth
and the USB.
So as Pete said at
the start, we're
letting you talk to devices.
And all of these are under the
experimental name space.
We should've mention that
you'll have to ask for
experimental permissions and
apps that are going into the
Chrome Web Store.
They don't allow you to use
those experimental APIs.
So this is very much a kind of
early stage thing where you
can put these in, start building
these apps, and then
as they become available
and stable--
RENATO MANGINI: Paul,
specifically about the
Bluetooth, just a warning that
it's being implemented on
Windows, Linux, and Mac.
Currently it only runs on Chrome
OS, but as we talk, the
engineer team is working
on the other platforms.
For Bluetooth only, OK?
So the developers should not
expect on these experimental
APIs, APIs completely
done and finished.
It will have a lot of changes.
Of course, there a lot of bugs,
probably, and we expect
the developer feedback
to fix those bugs.
PAUL LEWIS: Yes,
exactly right.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah, and I think
that's a good point that a lot
of these are in experimental
mode right now, and you can't
actually go and upload
experimental stuff to the
Chrome Web Store.
As these things start to mature
and as Chrome packaged
apps hit a maturity level later
this fall, we will have
a point where you will be
able to upload them.
You will actually be able to
go use them in real time
without having to have the
experimental flag on there and
know that they won't change
out from under you, where
right now, we're still making
sure they work and getting
feedback from you as you use
them to make sure that they
meet your needs and they
do the things that you
want them to do.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
One API I really wanted to pull
out at this stage and
something that I encourage you
guys to go and look at is, as
we said several times,
offline by default.
That's a really core
part of these apps.
And because of that,
things like storage
APIs are really helpful.
We've got chrome.storage.local
and chrome.storage.sync and
the sync version
of local and--
PETE LEPAGE: Do you have
feedback because I think you
just sort of bugged out
there for a second.
At least on my computer, so
maybe for other folks, too.
PAUL LEWIS: OK, so the APIs
you want to look at are
chrome.storage.local
and .sync.
And these are the two APIs
specifically for
storing your data.
They're specifically designed
for smaller amounts of data.
If you need larger amounts of
data, you might want to look
at the standard HTML5 File
System API and so forth.
But the point of these is that
they degrade gracefully like a
lot of the APIs.
They degrade gracefully under
poor network conditions, and
they are there specifically to
allow you to write sensible
offline focused apps.
So I really wanted to
make that point.
And then, as I said before,
we've got these other really
exciting APIs like the
system-level ones and so forth.
So go and have a look,
go and have a play.
Right now, what I'm going to
do is I'm actually going to
show you how you can get started
with the samples
because we've got a good
number of samples.
So I'm going to screenshare
once again.
And let's see what we see.
PETE LEPAGE: So with all of
these samples that Paul is
going to start showing you,
you can actually start
playing with them.
You'll need either Chrome Dev or
Chrome Canary because this
is not something that has made
it down to beta or to the
stable channel yet.
So you can always try it in
Chrome Canary or Chrome Beta--
or sorry, Chrome Canary
or Chrome Dev.
The one thing that I tend to
recommend is running Chrome
Canary and either Chrome Beta
or Chrome Stable because if
you do that, then you can have
two instances of Chrome
installed without having to
worry about them clobbering
each other.
You don't have to worry about
going and playing with
something in Chrome Canary and
having it crash on a regular
basis or anything like that
because it is Chrome Canary.
So if you have those two, you
can always go and play with
the latest stuff.
The other option would be to
install Chromium as a--
PAUL LEWIS: --which is
github.com/googl
echrome/chrome-app-samples
and--
PETE LEPAGE: All right, and
we'll provide a short link to
this in the notes.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
And so you can see we've got
a ton of samples here.
And again, I'll let you go and
have a play with those.
Now, the main thing that you'll
need to do is enable
the experimental
extension APIs.
Because when we ask-- as we
mentioned in the manifest, you
ask for permissions.
One of the permissions you're
going to be asking for is
experimental, almost certainly
as you try some of these
things out.
So you have to enable that
with a flag that you've
allowed to ask for that
particular permission.
So if you go to About Flags or
Chrome Flags, you'll see this
experimental extension APIs
which you enable.
And that's very important.
One of the things that we've
done to try and make your
lives a little bit
simpler, which I
really love, is we have--
I've got my channel open here.
We have something called Dojo,
which is under the Chrome App
Samples Folder.
I'm just going to
list that out.
You can see that I've got
a build script, so
if I just run build.
Takes a couple of seconds.
And out the other side.
If I go to my extensions
now, which I'll make
a little bit bigger--
and I'm in developer mode, which
allows me to load an
unpacked extension, which
can be useful sometimes.
If you go to the Dojo Build
folder and select that, you
get yourself a convenient new
app, which will allow you to
launch all the other samples.
So you can see when I go to a
new tab here, I've now got
this Chrome Apps Dojo,
which when I launch--
and you'll see the window
we were talking about.
This hasn't got any additional
Omnibox.
It's not got any
other buttons.
It's just a window--
PETE LEPAGE: That's a Chrome
packaged app, right?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, this is
a Chrome packed app.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet!
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So I'm going to just launch one
of our samples, which is a
single window.
We'll talk about these samples
in much more detail over the
coming weeks.
RENATO MANGINI: Paul?
Can I interrupt you a second?
There's a new version of Dojo
that is much better and much
reliable than this.
I'm not sure if you
want to run it.
Do you want me to broadcast here
or you quite happy with
this version?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah,
you go for it.
Yeah, if you've got
a newer version.
Yeah, feel free.
PETE LEPAGE: So I think the key
point here is that you can
actually go and sync--
use GitHub to just do a pull
and make sure that you've
always got the latest stuff so
that as we go and provide
updates, as we make changes to
the APIs, we're keeping the
samples and all that kind of
stuff up to date so that you
can stay up to date yourself.
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
So--
RENATO MANGINI: Go,
just go ahead.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
So what I'm actually going to
do is I'm also just going to
quickly show you one of the
other samples, which is the
Hello World.
So I'll actually load
that one directly.
You can see Hello World
just dropped in there.
You can see this little guy.
Got that.
[INAUDIBLE].
That's very handy.
So what I'll do is I'll now show
you the underlying code,
which is-- again, it's
really simple.
Just briefly, this is the
manifest, which if you've been
making apps to date you'll
recognize instantly.
It's just the JSON file.
Version 2 is important.
Bump the text up here.
PETE LEPAGE: Ah, that looks
much better, thank you.
PAUL LEWIS: OK.
Version 2 is what's going to
trip you into the new packaged
apps so that Chrome knows
that that's what
you're talking about--
name, version, icons.
And then this is the bit here
where you're saying, here's
the background script.
Here's the main hub of activity,
which in this case
is main.js.
And then I'm asking for the
experimental permissions, OK?
And then inside the main.js,
which is that background,
you'll see that we've got this
chrome.experimental.app
onLaunched, which is a list that
when your app is first
launched, this is the list that
we're going to have catch
that event.
And all it does is create a
window which says, inside,
Hello World.
So that's as much as you
need to start making
packaged apps today.
Obviously, all the samples
that we've got have got a
variety of APIs that they're
using and a variety of
permissions.
So there's plenty to
go up in this.
And we're going to be
adding more over
time I'm sure as well.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So again, to go get that stuff,
all you have to do is
go to GitHub, and you can
download the zip file there.
Or you can just clone the
repository to your local
machine, and you're
good to go.
PAUL LEWIS: Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: Sweet.
So what's the URL
for that again?
PAUL LEWIS: It's
github.com/googl
echrome/chrome-app-samples.
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
So this series of Office Hours
are something that we're going
to be doing pretty
much once a week.
We're going to do it every
Tuesday at 9:30 Pacific,
noon-30, or 12:30 Eastern.
And I think, Paul, for you in
London, it's 5:30 right
about-- well, I guess it's a
little after 5:30 now, but
we'll start at 5:30.
For those of you who are in
Brazil, we'll start at I guess
1:30 in the afternoon?
RENATO MANGINI: 1:30.
Exactly.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
So we're trying to get as much
of the world in as we can.
But one of the things that we
want to do is know what things
that you guys think are most
interesting, what APIs you
want us to focus on, what are
the pieces of the new Chrome
packaged apps that you really
want to dive into.
And so to do that, we'll
put the [INAUDIBLE]
and in the notes.
But we've got a survey
that we'd like you
guys to go fill out.
You can get to the survey
at goo.gl/7ZQUN.
All of those letters are
in capital letters.
Again, that's seven, Zed, Q,
U, N. Again, and we'll put
this in the slides so that you
can check that out after the
fact and fill that in.
Because we'll then choose
which sessions you
guys want to go for.
So at this point, I want to open
it up to your questions.
You guys have been submitting
questions through the Moderator.
And so we've taken a look.
We've got a few answers
already for us.
I'm going to take the first
question because it's a kind
of fun question and something
that we talked a little bit
about at I/O. But "when will
you support Chrome apps for
Android?" And at Google
I/O, [? Sendhar, ?]
as he was talking about these
new Chrome packaged apps or
the updated Chrome packaged
apps, said that this is
something that we want
to bring to other
platforms as well.
But we don't really have a date,
or we don't really have
a time frame where we've said,
hey, this is going to happen
within this date or time yet.
We want to make sure that we
get the new APIs locked and
really solid before
we do that.
We want to make sure that we
get the experience great.
We want to make sure that we get
this piece right before we
start moving on and moving
to other parts.
The second question is another
fun question here.
"What are the top three
conditions to get featured on
the Chrome Web Store?
Do you give preference to apps
using Google Checkout, HTML5,
requiring users to sign in
via Google Accounts?"
And typically the thing that
we say to folks is that we
just want you to go build
really great web apps.
As developer advocates and
developer programs engineers,
I think we all have a different
list of things that
we look at in terms
of great apps.
And that's a great question for
us to bring up in a future
event, are what are some
of those things.
In general, I want it
to feel really appy.
I want it to look beautiful.
I want it to have a really
good user experience.
The other thing that I recommend
people do is have a
look at the Web App
Field Guide.
So if you go to html5rocks.com/w
ebappfieldguide, there's some
good information there.
Paul, Renato, do you guys have
anything that you look for in
a really great web app?
PAUL LEWIS: No, for me,
I think you hit
the nail on the head.
It's got to be something
that people love using.
And I think a well-built app,
well executed that fills a
real user need.
That's what I personally
would be looking for.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, exactly.
I second that.
It's a perfect answer.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
So somebody asked a question,
"what are the limitations of
app scripts embedded
in Google sites?
For example, what libraries,
APIs cannot be included?" I
don't really have
a good handle on
the apps script stuff.
But the apps scripts team does
a Hangout on Thursdays.
This week it's at 11:30
Eastern time.
I'd recommend you go to that
Hangout and ask them there.
They're more than happy to
answer, and they're a good
group of folks.
"So why are there no human
interface guidelines for
Chrome OS and Chrome
packaged apps?
I seriously doubt that Chrome
apps can compete with native
apps without having a consistent
look and feel."
Paul, do you want to
take this one?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah.
Let me--
yeah.
So I think what we would say
is that consistent UX, UI,
that's really important stuff.
And we want to make sure that
what we say adds up, and it
makes sense to users, and it
makes sense to developers.
And so it's something that we've
been talking about in
terms of we don't have a release
or anything like that.
But we do think that's good, and
it's a really good idea.
PETE LEPAGE: And just a
reminder, if you have
questions, you can go post them
on the Moderator, and
vote questions up and down.
The questions that you want to
hear answers to, vote them up.
The ones that you're not really
interested in, vote
them down, or if you think
it's not a good question.
Because we'll take your
questions here.
So Jarek from, I think, Poland
has another question.
"When will we have full control
over main menu and
context menus in
packaged apps?
Currently, there's nowhere to
set up a main application menu
on the OS X standard Chrome
menu as shown.
And the context menu can only
extend with submenus." Renato,
do you want to answer
that one?
RENATO MANGINI: Sure.
Yeah, you are absolutely
right, Jarek.
The main menu currently cannot
be changed currently, but it's
being worked on.
And the context menu, I
saw your email on the
Chrome New Apps list.
And the current API exists,
and we want your feedback.
I would ask you to please submit
this feedback through
crbug.com with a special use
case that you cannot do with
current context menu.
And we will work with the
engineering team to check that
and perhaps even change the
API if it makes sense for
broad audience.
But definitely this feedback's
very important for us.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
Cool.
So [? Virchow ?]
from Mumbai said he's "made a
GWT application and is trying
to make it a packaged app, but
he's facing some issues.
What would be the best way to
solve those issues?" And he
posted a link to his
specific question.
RENATO MANGINI: Can
I answer that?
Yeah, absolutely.
RENATO MANGINI: OK, I'm
a GWT developer, also.
So one of the first things I
look at when I start working
with Chrome apps was how I could
move GWT applications to
the Chrome apps.
And there are some issues,
because we haven't talked
about this today, but we'll talk
a lot about CSP on the
next session.
And CSP is a set of restrictions
that the Chrome
app must follow to
be a Chrome app.
And some of these restrictions,
and
[? Virchow ?]
you know that, because you
posted that on your question,
it just allow some of the
features of GWT, G-W-T. A
simple GWT application should
work on a sandbox iframe.
I'm sorry for the audience
that have not heard about
sandbox iframes.
We'll talk about that
later, also.
But some of the--
PETE LEPAGE: Let's just talk--
I'll give a 30-second
version of that.
Content Security Policy
basically says it protects
your apps from--
helps to protect your apps
from cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities.
And it limits [INAUDIBLE]
can run, how it gets run, and a
couple of things like that.
So that means within Chrome
packaged apps, you can't do a
certain set of things, but you
can have a sandboxed iframe
that allows those things
to happen.
But it's sandbox.
So it lives off in its own
little world, and you can't
easily communicate with the
rest of your application.
So Renato, I'll pass it back
to you and you can--
RENATO MANGINI: OK, so GWT
compiles your code and it uses
some of the things that
CSP tries to avoid,
which is new function--
the use and the construction
of the
function with string scripts.
So you were supposed to run a
very simple GWT application on
a sandbox iframe.
If you are not, I would ask you
to submit a simple sample
that doesn't work, and
we'll check it out.
We'll try to make it happen.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
a great point.
If you find bugs as you're
building these things, if
things aren't working right, the
forums are a great place
to go post your questions.
But as well, file
bugs with us.
We need to hear about these
things so that we can get them
fixed and ready for you to go
start using in real-- in
production code.
So the next question is "can we
get an API like the Chrome
storage sync that syncs to our
own custom back-end point."
And that's a great feature
request from Rob in Montana.
Rob, it would be great if you
could go file that on Chromium
bugs so that we can go and start
looking into that and
see what happens.
But that's the best place to
go file feature requests or
anything like that.
So the next question from
Anatoly in the European Union.
"Awesome news on ways to
authenticate users via Google
through an API.
However, the dialogue looks
really scary to users like
developers are going to
steal their email.
Facebook has an option to
provide an anonymous ID of
users without asking for email."
I guess that's not
really a question, but maybe
a feature request.
So Anatoly, if you would,
again, same thing.
Go file a feature request on the
Chrome apps or in the bug
database, that would be great.
So we've got a couple
minutes left.
But "do you have any plans for
exposing names of system fonts
to packaged apps?" This is a
must for any app that provides
rich text editing capabilities."
And Jarek has
an API proposal already
as a gist on GitHub.
Paul, do you want to talk
about this for a sec?
PAUL LEWIS: Yeah, I think just
generally about fonts.
I mean, if it's a system font
that is obviously, it comes
with the OS, then you should
be able to use CSS as you
normally would.
You should expect the standard
browser behavior there.
If you're considering embedding
fonts, you should
consider the offline first
thing that you won't be
loading those resources
remotely, That you'll want to
bundle up those fonts
with your app.
And obviously you need to make
sure that you check any
licensing and so forth
to do with that.
But in general, what you're
suggesting, which I think is
can we pull a list of fonts on
this particular system, I
think that it's another
feature request.
It's a great feature request.
Please file it as such, and we
will take a look at it with
the engineering team and see
what we can do there.
PETE LEPAGE: All
right, awesome.
Well, Renato, I'm going to pass
the next question to you.
"What's the difference between
the browser tag and an iframe
tag with the sandbox attribute
introduced in HTML5?
Aren't iframes already running
in a separate process?"
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah.
The browser tag is
also a new thing
for most of the audience.
The idea of the browser tag is
to be a completely separate
instance of a browser-like
element.
So it has its own cookie jar
it has it own storage, and
it's completely independent
of your app, in general.
The iframe tag, the sandbox
iframe, is different because
the idea is to be part
of your application.
None of those are--
we created those to support
a few use cases.
But our idea is not that you
are using both of these.
Our idea is to really use the
power of Chrome apps.
You should use those only if you
cannot do the same thing
going outside of both browser
tag and iframe tag.
So to simply answer the
tech, the iframe--
the answer to the question is
the iframe tag is part of your
application.
The browser tag is to be a
complete separate part of a
complete separate process.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right, well, we'll take one
more question, and then
we're a little bit over time.
Next question is "why would you
deprecate Flash in favor
of making developers rewrite all
their stuff in HTML5?" And
I'd like all three of us to
answer this because I think
this is a really cool reason to
me, is that we really think
HTML5 provides all of the
features and power and, in
fact, even more than
Flash does.
And we really want to see the
web built on open standards
and take advantage of the things
that we can now do with
HTML5 that we've never been
able to do before.
With things like CSS animations,
with transitions,
you can get some pretty awesome
experiences that work
across all devices, no matter
where the user's coming from.
So by pushing these towards an
open platform you get a lot
more users.
You get a lot more ability to do
stuff, and I think it's the
way that the platform's
really moving.
Paul, Renato, you want
to take a stab?
PAUL LEWIS: You covered the main
points that I would have
got there, Pete.
Well played.
I think it's exactly
as you said.
I mean, the promise of the web
to some degree is ubiquity.
And certainly HTML5 and
its support across--
there's numerous devices that
we're seeing in tablets, and
phones that have really come
on in the last few years.
They're a much closer
match to HTML5.
And we see, as Pete said, that's
the direction that the
industry's been going in.
And we're putting our weight
behind that and supporting
that as the appropriate
platform,
really, on which to build.
PETE LEPAGE: Yeah.
RENATO MANGINI: Yeah, I
understand the rage of the
developer that has already
developed application and just
want to move to the new platform
without changing
anything it's completely
understandable.
But there's so many new and cool
things on the HTML5 side
that I suggest that if you
have a Flash application,
consider moving it to HTML5.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
All right, so I think that
about wraps up for today.
We're going to be back with you
guys live next Tuesday.
Again at 9:30 Pacific, 12:30
Eastern, 5:30 in London.
And in fact, we're going to
be joined by another Paul.
We'll have two Pauls.
And it's always fun to
have more Pauls.
And in fact, a bunch of
us are all going to
be in the same location.
So we'll have a fun little
opportunity to interact right
next to each other.
So with that, I'll say thank
you guys very much.
Look forward to seeing you
again in the near future.
PAUL LEWIS: Thanks.
Guys, fill in the survey.
Make sure you tell us what
you want to hear about.
RENATO MANGINI: Thank
you guys.
Thank you, bye.
PETE LEPAGE: All righty,
buh-bye.